- [Announcer] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website, or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked large-brained. Long the
master of fire, tools and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable, yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here. An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Bernard] This is a topic that I have
been thinking about for some time as you
can gauge by the difference in hair color
in that picture and now. But what I want
to do today is to try and use the
experience of those years to see whether
it's taught me anything and also to use
some data from some young people. And I'm
very grateful to Eve Boyle and to Andrew
Du and to David Patterson who are all
graduate students in the Home Power
Program at the university where I come
from. And I'm mentioning Mark Collard here
because he and I worked on this now a
little time ago and I'm going to say some
things that he might or might not agree
with and I'm just giving him a warning. So
what, what are we looking for? Homo is a
genus and when Mark and I started to think
about this, we could not find a definition
of a genus that was universally supported.
So we put together, for our own purposes,
a working definition of a genus and we
suggested that it was "a species or a
monophyletic group whose members occupy a
single adaptive zone." Now let me try and
unpack some of that. For a species to be
included in a genus, it should belong to
the same monophyletic group as the type
species of that genus. Now the type
species of a genus Homo is Homo sapiens so
what we argued was that the different
species deserve to belong to Homo then it
should be in the same monophyletic group.
Now a slightly shorter term for
monophyletic group is the word clade and
how do you define a clade? The definition
that we use was "all of the taxa, no more
and no less, that are descended from a
recent common ancestor." Now I like
metaphors from the car industry and so as
not to let my colleagues down, I got some
new ones here. The common ancestor of all
Toyotas is a Toyoda, it's a model which
was developed in 1935 by a company, the
company originally made machinery to made
textiles. So it did not start as a car
company, but they decided that they wanted
to make cars and they went to America to
learn how to make cars then they went back
to Japan and they made a car, and it was
the A1. So that's the common ancestor of
all the models of Toyota that are and have
ever been. So that's what we're looking
for. The notion of the second criterion
was that for a species to be included in
Homo its adaptive strategy should be
closer to the one of the type species,
i.e.modern humans, than to the type
species of any other genus. So the
candidate species that we are thinking
about including in the genus Homo, that
and the type species should be part of the
same grade. So, what is a grade? It's just
a series of questions that I keep... So a
grade is "a group of taxa that shares a
suite of what we call adaptive features."
So we would suggest that if you do share
those features you are in the same
adaptive zone. So back to the cars. So the
Toyota Motor Company decided that it
should make a jeep. It saw the success of
the Willys Jeep, it was a four wheel drive
car. So it decided to make its own four
wheel drive car. My suggestion is that as
soon as you make a four wheel drive car,
you are in a new adaptive zone. You are in
a different adaptive zone and this is the
one that they made. And so my contention
is that in the Toyota clade, that the BJ
which is what this is, marked the
beginning of a new adaptive zone of four
wheel drive vehicles. Now you could argue
that hybrid cars might be a new adaptive
zone as well. You could argue that the
design of a minivan which was introduced
by the Toyota Motor Company and it was
called very imaginatively the first one,
it was called a van. Okay. And then the
next model was called the Previa, and the
model that exceeded that was the one that
you see now called the Sienna. My
contention and my suggestion is that the
notion of a minivan is a new adaptive
zone. There are levels of sophistication.
Now the doors open electronically and you
can argue that, you know, does the
addition of electronic opening doors make
it a new adaptive zone? That's up to you.
My sense is that it's not much different
as to whether you open the door yourself
or whether they open electrically and so I
wouldn't call that a different adaptive
zone. So here, there are people who are
interested in the evolution of the four
wheel drive vehicles made by Toyota. And
here is an image that was very kindly
found for me by another graduate student
who is called Alexander Pruca [SP], and
you can see that there are people who are
interested in the evolutionary history of
the Land Cruiser. And so, they are
interested in what we are interested in.
But the problem is but if all the evidence
you had for the evolutionary history of
the Toyota was a few fragments, maybe part
of the windshield, a little bit of the
wheel, something from the grill, a little
bit of the fender, or something from the
hood. And the problem is you didn't even
have the same parts for the different
models that you're trying to link. That
gives you a sense of what we are trying to
do. We do not have the equivalent of the
luxury of all this information about the
models and the developments within the
evolutionary history of the Toyota Land
Cruiser. So the second question, what
about the who? The genus Homo was
established by Linnaeus way back in the
18th century. And as the years have gone
by, more and more taxa have been added and
they have been included in the genus. So
initially, the neanderthals were included
and then the taxon called Homo
heidelbergensis and then the taxon called
Homo rudolfensis and then a taxon called
Homo soloensis. And maybe the biggest
addition was made by Ernst Mayr during the
second World War when he suggested that
the taxa that had been in the genus of the
genera, tymantrabus and the genus
phyticantrobus, should be included in
Homo. So as the years went by, the genus
Homo became more and more inclusive. The
criteria for admission were relaxed. The
initial criterion was you had to have a
brain as large as ours. So admitting Homo
neanderthalensis, that wasn't a big, that
wasn't a huge deal because they had large
brains, too. But by the time you get to
including Homo erectus in Homo you are
admitting that this is a genus that can
have individuals that can have brains half
the size of the average modern human. Then
in 1964, Louis Leakey and the person of
the Leakeys had recruited to help them
interpret the anatomy of their fossils,
Phillip Tobias and John Napier, they
published a paper in Nature suggesting
that some fossil that had been found at
Olduvai should be included in a new
species and that species name was habilis.
But maybe more controversially, they
suggested that that species should be
included in Homo. Now that meant relaxing
the criteria even more and the question
is, was that process of relaxation, that
last process of relaxation, to what extent
did that stay within the definition of a
genus that Mark and I suggested? In other
words, is Homo habilis part of the same
clade and is Homo habilis part of the same
grade? What we argued in a paper in
Science way back was that we didn't think
the evidence was all that strong, but
let's get back to that. So how has this
process of progressive inclusivity
affected the grade definition of Homo?
This is an extremely speciose
interpretation of the Hominin fossil
record. Modern humans are in the top left.
What I call a gray...which I call
pre-modern Homo which includes
neanderthals and the heidelbergensis and
Homo erectus is in the blue. And then the
hominids that Bill Kimble is going to be
talking about, the mustard colored ones
are down in the bottom right. And then
there are some rather brownish ones which
are rather like the mustard colored ones
except they have extremely large molars
and pre-molars. These are animals with
very large mandibles and very large post
canine teeth. So the inclusion of Homo
habilis in Homo meant that the genus Homo
would include what I've called pre-modern
Homo plus the taxa that have called
transitional homonins on the basis of the
findings that Mark and I published way
back in 1999. Now I think that paper was
superbly well argued and was extremely
clearly written, but it made hardly any
impression on my colleagues. And it's fair
to say that apart from a few discerning
and discriminating scientists, most people
still include the taxa Homo habilis and
Homo rudolfensis within the genus Homo. So
that's one way of interpreting the genus
Homo. So the origin of the genus Homo
would be how do you explain the appearance
of Homo habilis? That's another way of
asking the same question. In which case,
you would include Homo habilis and Homo
rudolfensis which is some people think
might be distinct from Homo habilis but
it's a similar sort of organism. You would
include them in the dark blue category, in
the dark blue grade. If Mark and I are
correct then you would extend the genus
Homo down that far. You would
stop at the beginning of Homo erectus. In
which case you would regard Homo habilis
and Homo rudolfensis as not the same
species as the other australopiths but
nonetheless, within the same adaptive zone
as the other australopiths. So what has
happened since the publication of the
paper in Science that nobody took any
notice of in 1999? More fossil evidence
has been found and not only has more
fossil evidence...more fossils been found
that the existing fossils have been
reanalyzed and reconstructed and so on. So
that's one development. The other
development is that we have new data and
there people who are reassessing the
existing data which relate to what I call
the functional capacities of these
animals. What can we infer about how
dextrous they were? What can we infer
about how smart they were? What can we
infer about what they were eating? These
are just a few of the publications that
are relevant to this, but I want to talk
about the categories of the data that
speak to cognition and some new data that
speak to diet. Now in relation to
cognition, these are not new data. Most of
the data that were analyzed were the
specimens which were used by Leslie Aiello
who's in the audience and she will be
speaking later. And this was a plot which
was published in a paper and this was a
paper which looked at the relationship
between brain size and other revolutionary
trends. And it was this plot which gave
rise to this notion that there was a
burst, there was a period of relatively
sudden increase in brain size of the
origin of the genus Homo and then there
was another burst of increase in brain
size at the origin of the species Homo
sapiens. But these data, the plot looks as
if it is consistent with that
interpretation, but the plot represents
each value as one point. And the problem
with the plot is that the data are subject
to error. In other words, there is error
in the estimation of the endocranial
volume and there is error in the
estimation of the age. So what a bunch of
graduate students did led by Andrew Du was
to look at these data again. And so these
are the data and it's the other way
around, in other words, the older data are
to the left and the younger data on to the
right. So those are also point data. But
then if you add the error, the error of
the age and the error of the estimation of
the endocranial volume, you see that the
data look rather different. Then when you
do some very fancy statistics, which I was
very tempted to pretend that I knew what
they were but I decided that I wasn't
going to pretend that I knew what they
were. And then they tested the data
against various modes of change, random
walk, or gradualism, or stasis, or
punctuated equilibrium which was the
hypothesis of the relatively sudden
increase in brain size, and so on and so
forth. They found that the mode
which had much the greatest amount of
support was gradualism. So in other words,
the data if you account for the error of
the age and the estimate of the
endocranial volume, there is no evidence
of a punctuated event. So how about diet?
Well, this is work of David Pattison. And
you can see here that there are three
color bands. The australopiths that Bill
is going to be talking about. So you can
see they are in the light green band and
then the first of the red columns
represents the early evidence for Homo in
the Turkana Basin which is either Homo
habilis or it's Homo rudolfensis. And then
the second of the red columns is the
evidence for Homo in the Turkana Basin
which is Homo erectus or Homo ergaster. So
if the major grade shift was between the
australopiths and the first red column,
you wouldn't expect the first red column
to be where it is because these are carbon
isotope values. So there is a shift
between the first red column, in other
words, Homo habilis and the second red
column which is Homo erectus. Here is
David and he's the one who's collected
these data. So if you look at this plot,
you can see the blue squares are
Paranthropus boisei who are living in
exactly the same lake basin as what is
alleged to be Homo habilis and widely
accepted to be Homo erectus. And there is
no change in isotopic signal or the
Paranthropus boisei individuals, but there
is a change in isotopic signal for Homo.
So there is a more C3 signal for Homo
habilis and then there is a significantly
different, more C4 signal for Homo
erectus. You might say, "Well, that's just
because the environment was changing and
everything was changing and Paranthropus
boisei was the only large mammal that
wasn't changing." Well, that's not true.
If you look at all the other large
mammals, they don't change and
Paranthropus boisei doesn't change, it's
just Homo that does. So there is a dietary
shift from Homo habilis to Homo erectus
and the isotopic signal for the diet of
Homo habilis is no different from the
isotopic signals of the creatures that
proceeded it and we call australopiths. So
my suggestion is that we just should not
assume that the interesting things were
happening around the appearance of Homo
habilis. My suggestion is no different
from the suggestion we made in the paper
in 1999, that most of the action is around
the appearance of Homo erectus and it's
not around the appearance of Homo habilis.
Thank you very much.
♪ [music] ♪